harlow in essex one of the most deprived
towns in this county nearly two-thirds
of people here with less than 125 pounds
of spare cash each month it's a place
where every penny counts and the cost of
living squeeze is real
hi robert well thanks for having us down
in harlow today
the conservative mp here desperate for
the pm to prioritize pounds in pockets
over parties my worry about everything
that's gone on is that this is a
distraction
because they're all focused on fire
fighting when they should be focused on
helping uh the public uh cut their bills
when the real elephant in the room is
that people are struggling to feed their
families and uh to have a decent quality
of life and it's in these classrooms
where people are feeling it are you
finding families are finding it hard
going at the moment
yeah i think it's impacting on everybody
after school clubs running once more at
geron's primary and while the children
play the mums reflect on not just the
emotional cost of cavid
but their current worries over the cost
of living how is your household budgets
are you managing are you uh i'm also i'm
a single parent so it will hit me
um i did have the extra universal credit
when it was in place
yeah and it's obviously that's now gone
wages they're not necessarily going up
in line with inflation for the cost of
living
but you've noticed it like when you go
to the supermarket you have most
definitely yeah yeah of course yeah i
mean whereas before you knew how much
your weekly bill was going to be or what
the cost of your
energy bill was going to be now
you're too scared almost but concerns
over everyday life overshadowed by the
boris johnson party scandal too do you
feel that when he made that apology did
that make you kind of forgive him a bit
if you're just saying it to get yourself
out of trouble because even my
ten-year-old son said he's only sorry
because he's been cool and that's very
perspective from a child
but i would also i'm more looking at the
bigger picture yeah who's going to run
the country if he's pushed out of office
what's your view of it all on the past
year does it bother you yes
i
really really struggled and then he's
there having parties laughing cheese and
wine hahaha
and
we're just stuck at home following the
rules
i didn't see anyone when i really should
have because i was in a crisis moment
the cost of living crisis set to get
worse
tax rises and spikes in energy bills
will hit communities like this all over
the land the pm consumed by the party
scandal firefighting to save his job as
another crisis lies in wait beth rigby
sky news harlow